when in doubt hit them with the twist
that seems to have been the thought
process of avengers endgame
screenwriters Christopher Markus and
Stephen McFeely who recently sat down
with the New York Times to discuss the
film's plot in the wake of its runaway
success the twist in question occurs
early in the bill when the remaining
Avengers tracked down Thanos now living
on the lonely planet he retreated to
after snuffing out half of all life in
the universe their goal to swipe the
Infinity stones and use them to undo the
mad Titans damage but upon arriving they
find that Thanos has used the power of
the stones to reduce them to atoms
rendering their mission moot in a moment
of pure frustration Thor does what he
should have done during the battle of
Wakanda and went for the head killing
the most formidable foe the Avengers had
ever faced roughly twenty minutes into
the movie it was a shocking narrative
decision one which Markus and McFeely
admitted they struggled to pin down
McFeely told the New York Times we
always had this problem Thanos has the
ultimate weapon he can see an attack
coming it's ridiculous at some point
executive producer Trent ran went can't
we just kill him and we all went what
happens if you just kill him why would
you kill him why would he let you kill
him the answer to that question is
simple Thanos had accomplished what he
set out to do Marcus explained it
reinforced Thanos his agenda he was done
not to make it too christ-like but it
was like if I've got to die I can die
now and then one
I finally rest watch the sunrise on a
grateful universe
Thor's brutal beheading of the mad Titan
benefited no one however it was an act
of pure frustration and one which was
never going to bring back the Infinity
stones or any of the Avengers fallen
comrades in fact it seems likely that
the noblest Guardians desperate vengeful
killing of Thanos may have been the
final straw and causing him to spiral
into a years-long pout with depression
but this also gave Thor who has gone
from a rather OneNote hero to arguably
the most fascinating and complex
character in the MCU one of endgames
most emotionally satisfying arcs it
wasn't until his encounter with his
mother Frigga in 2013 during the
Avengers time heist to recover the
Infinity stones that he came to terms
with his failure it all fell into place
neatly for Markus and McFeely who had
gone into the screenwriting process with
little idea of where they could take the
ass Guardians personal journey during
endgame
Markus said when we were spitballing for
endgame we started with Thor's on a
mission of vengeance and then we were
like he was on a mission of vengeance in
the last movie this is all this guy ever
does lets drive him into a wall and see
what happens in the end by compounding
his failure to stop Thanos in a moment
of weakness
the near immortal God was made more
relatable to the audience than he ever
had been before while Marvel continue
exploring the journey of Odinson at
phase 4 and Beyond of all the original
Avengers it makes the most sense for the
god of thunder story to continue and
Chris Hemsworth has proven himself more
than capable of taking the character to
more interesting places than anyone ever
expected but will he play a key role in
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 going into
action to face some new cosmic threat
will he return for another crossover
team-up film at some points in the MCU
future or will he become the first
Avenger to get a fourth solo flick only
time will tell
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
Avengers and gamer coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]